en el último vídeo nos introducimos a la
ley de la oferta y fue una idea de
sentido común que si dejamos algunas
cosas igual fijas y el precio de algo
sube es más motivante para que más
productores lo produzcan produzcan más
de ese producto y lo vimos en el vídeo
pasado mientras el precio sube nos
movíamos por esta curva de la oferta y
la cantidad producida también subían
ahora lo que yo quiero ver en este vídeo
es todo lo que mantuvimos fijo en el
vídeo pasado y la primera de éstas es
número 1 precios en las entradas precios
en las entradas otra manera de pensarlo
es el costo de producción entonces si el
precio de las entradas quizás el precio
de la mano de obra las personas que
arrancan las uvas o la gasolina que
necesitamos para transportar las uvas o
la tierra si cualquiera de estas de
éstos sube en cualquier precio dado
haríamos menos dinero imagina que eso
solamente se maneja para uvas tendríamos
muy pocas ganancias y quizás digamos ok
como ya es caro conseguir semillas de
uvas plantas de otra cosa porque no
estoy obteniendo la ganancia deseada por
cada kilo de uvas que vendo entonces si
el precio de mis entradas sube
si aumentan mis costos en cualquier
punto de precio dado yo quiero producir
menos así que si el precio de mis
entradas aumenta entonces la oferta la
oferta bajará y así si por ejemplo en
este punto de precio yo hago menos
dinero producirá también menos o quizá
el mejor de guaje mejor produzco otra
cosa y así toda la curva de la oferta se
moverá se moverá así todas hacia la
izquierda
justamente quedará así y de hecho
también en el precio mínimo también el
precio ahí subirá aunque no exista
oferta porque bueno me costó más aún por
producir esta primera unidad y
análogamente si el precio de mis
entradas fuera abajo ahora en cualquier
punto de precio las uvas darán más
ganancia y así estaremos más motivados
para producir uvas usar más tierra para
uvas que para cualquier otro producto y
tendríamos toda esta curva toda la curva
se trasladará a la derecha
ahora bien número 2 número 2 pensemos en
bienes relacionados
sucede con el precio de bienes
relacionados y cuando pensamos en estas
cosas no debemos pensarlas desde el
punto de vista de la demanda porque
estamos pensando estamos hablando de
oferta y lo quieres pensar desde el
punto de vista del productor
cuando hablamos de bienes relacionados
queremos pensar en sustitutos de
producción y bueno quizás yo soy un
agricultor y bueno de hecho no sé nada
de esto de siempre y esas cosas no sé
sea posible de lo que hablo pero
supongamos que lo soy y quizás tengo mi
tierra emitiera una parte para uvas y la
otra parte para arándanos así que qué
pasaría si el precio de un bien
relacionado qué pasaría si el precio de
los arándanos subiera pues si el precio
de los arándanos subiera yo diría agua o
quizás me convenga más usar más tierra
para sembrar arándanos que para sembrar
lo que es uvas y otros productos porque
me conviene más arándanos así que una
vez más si el precio de mis bienes
relacionados si el precio de mis de mis
productos sustitutos bueno el mejor lo
voy a escribir aquí lo escribo de esta
manera
a precios de otras cosas otras cosas que
puedo producir si el precio de otras
cosas que yo puedo producir llegará a
subir sube entonces mi oferta de uvas lo
que sucede es que bajará y lo importante
aquí es que en cualquiera de estas
circunstancias bueno de hecho piénsalo
no solamente veas lo que escribo
escuches lo que digo no lo memorice aquí
bueno simplemente es una manera de
pensar las cosas y obviamente si yo
puedo hacer más dinero de arándanos
entonces yo voy a usar más tierra para
sembrar arándanos que para qué para uvas
o otra cosa y la oferta de uvas va a
bajar y ahora ahora pensemos en qué
sucede con el número de proveedores
número 3 número 3 número de proveedores
y esto es básicamente sentido común
entre más personas entre más
abastecimiento mayor la oferta entonces
si el número de proveedores sube y bueno
esta es una curva de la oferta agregada
así que si el número de proveedores
aumenta entonces la oferta agregada
subirá en cualquier punto del precio
dado si el número de proveedores
bajará entonces la oferta agregada
también bajará en cualquier punto de
precio dado creo que eso es algo obvio
entonces bueno podemos pensar ahora en
tecnología quizás hay una innovación un
nuevo tipo de semilla mágica que con
buena no mágica que con la misma
cantidad de trabajo la misma cantidad de
de tierra podemos producir esa misma
cantidad de uvas o quizás más quién sabe
si tenemos mejoras tecnológicas lo estoy
asumiendo no entraremos tratar de esos
curas si tenemos mejoras tecnológicas
también la oferta entonces la oferta
subirá claro que sí claro que sí también
subirá también lo puedes pensar como que
ahora será más barato producir es lo
mismo entonces el precio de las entradas
bajará eso hará que tu oferta suba o
dirás hey mira habrá un nuevo tipo de
uvas brotando de estas nuevas viñas que
obtuvimos entonces produciremos más uvas
también así lo puedes ver y bueno número
5 un poco raro para esta analogía de las
uvas pero lo pondré número 5 tan tan tan
tambores los precios futuros esperados
es el número 5 lo voy a poner como
expectativas de precios futuros de hecho
hay que alejarnos de las uvas por un
momento porque son bienes perecederos se
marchitan no son como que los puedes
guardar y después usarlos excepto cuando
ya sabes pasas pero digamos que tú eres
un productor de aceite aceite es algo
que tú puedes guardar y usar después y
tienes la expectativa de que los precios
del aceite se mantendrán neutrales así
que bueno mañana tú dices ok los precios
van a subir en el futuro tú estás seguro
de que hoy de hoy en un año los precios
del aceite atravesarán los techos
entonces cuál es tu incentivo lo que vas
a hacer es guardar todo tu aceite no lo
vas a vender al menos no por hoy porque
lo guardarás en el para qué para
venderlo en el futuro si estás seguro
claro de qué es lo que va a pasar
entonces si tú lo que esperas si hay un
cambio las expectativas de precios
futuros es decir si con tu producto tú
vas de neutral a el aumento de
expectativas de precios los precios
aumentan en el futuro entonces vas a
guardar tu bien y no puedes guardar uvas
porque porque se marchitan las puedes de
hecho convertir en vino o pasas pero si
hablamos de algo como lo que es aceite
entonces dirás
hey porque yo debo vender mi producto en
el precio de hoy el cual es un precio es
un precio bajo mejor yo voy a bajar mi
oferta de hoy para venderla en el futuro
entonces si las expectativas de precios
futuros van de lo que es neutral y tú
tienes la expectativa de que los precios
subirán dramáticamente entonces lo que
sucederá es que la oferta actual bajará
la oferta actual bajará y la podrás
guardar para venderla en el futuro bueno
hasta pronto